in der Früh einen Termin gehabt wo ich
dringend hi Hop mercen und das war was
wo man mit dem Auto Hinfahrt und er hat
das Kassen hat am Wochenende das ab
Montag also absolute Chaos herrscht mit
diesem ganzen Streiks im Nahverkehr
Fernverkehr und schlecht nur Verkehr und
da habe ich jetzt seit gedacht puh also
über den auch die Autobahn in Sankt
knappe voll ist wird Staus ohne Ende
geben und da hat man eventuell heute
Sturm früher los dann kriegt man die
Schuhe hoffentlich und dann haben wir
denkt oder sicherheitshalber
verkehrsnachricht nur und trotzdem
heilende früher Kosten das auf der A 995
keine Ahnung wo die ist dass da Unfall
war und deswegen ist kommt so leicht
Verzögerungen das war euch
und da haben wir denkt der Typ der
gewarnt hat dass die Autobahnen knacke
voll sind alle ist es eigentlich Art der
Typ der im letzten Sommer gesagt hat
dass im Winter keine
Veranstaltungen geben wird weil die
ganzen Veranstaltungsräume belegt sein
werden als Wärmestuben für Menschen der
hoheitsgasse total ausgeht und der noch
davor waren hat das in allen
Krankenhäusern zur Triage kommt ist es
immer derselbe oder wechseln Sie die ab
keine Ahnung